تخيل ان تستيقظ وتجد ان حسابك على فيسبوك
قد تم حظره اذا حصلت هناك احتمالا اما ان
الحسابه خلق قواعد الشركه او انه تم
اختراقه اذا اقترضنا الاسوء احتمال
الاحتمال الثاني فنحن امام خيارين اللجوء
للطرق الاليه لاستعاده الحساب او التواصل
مع فنيه عبر الهاتف او عبر البريد
الالكتروني وغالبا لا يكون ذلك مشكله
ساخنا يمنح موظف نيته ميزه لاسترجاع
حساباتي معرفه الاصدقاء والعائله والشركات
التجاريين والشخصيات العامه بعمليه بسيطه
يسرد الموظف عنوان البريد الكتروني
والدرابطه بحسابي فيسبوك او انستقرام
ويجيب على اسئله تفسر علاقته بمالك الحساب
ثم يوجه الطلب الى يوجه الطلاب الى الدعم
الفني وخلال ايام تح ايه المشكله
حظروا هذه الخدمه السريعه على معظم
المستخدمي التطبيق خلق سوقا سوداء لوسطاء
لوسطاء من داخل وخارج الشركه الاهتزازي
وسرقه واستعاده حسابات مستخدمين لمقابل
المادي
بروكامررد عارضه ازياء يتابعها
656,000 شخص على انستقرام دفعه 7000 دولار
لصاحب شركه تربطه علاقته عملته لاستعاده
حسابها طبعا متى فتحت تحقيقا وعلى اثره
اقامه بفصل او تاديب اكثر من 20 موظفا
ومقاولا المفارقه ان من بينهم من عمل حارس
امن للشركه
فضيحه فعلا لكن هي ليست الاولى
قضيه ثانيه كشفتها كيف باعت الشركات
معلومات شخصيه عن المستخدمين الشركات
التسويق مقابل الملايين الدولارات اذا
كانت الشركه نفسها متورطه فمن
بياناتنا وهل لخصوصياتنا سعد